I know that everybody's like,
so hurt and sad
cause sweet little Mike Tyson lost that fight to Jake Paul.
But can we please remember that Mike Tyson was a wife beater?
He was when he was in his heyday,
and he was Iron Mike Tyson.
He was using that same strength and force
against the women he was with.
there's probably a lot of women that could give no fucks that he won,
and they're probably happy that he.
You know what I mean? Like,
there's so many people in this world that he hurt.
So, you know,
before we go shedding a ton of tears for Mike Tyson.
I get it. I watched the fight too.
Um, like,
try to remember. That's why men will get away with stuff.
They get older
and then we'll just forget everything they did and be like, oh,
but it like, okay,
he's a violent man that was violent his whole life,
and violence is even a part of his end of days.
Like, I don't.
I don't know, I don't know.
There's not a whole lot of sympathy.
And he also got paid. Like,
can we please save your tears for anything but Mike Tyson?